[Music]
cigarettes aren't good for us that's
hardly news we've known about the
dangers of smoking for decades but how
exactly to cigarettes harm us let's look
at what happens as their ingredients
make their way through our bodies and
how we benefit physically when we
finally give up smoking with each
inhalation smoke brings its more than
5,000 chemical substances into contact
with the body's tissues from the start
tar a black resinous material begins to
coat the teeth and gums damaging tooth
enamel and eventually causing decay over
time smoke also damages nerve endings in
the nose causing loss of smell inside
the airways and lungs smoke increases
the likelihood of infections as well as
chronic diseases like bronchitis and
emphysema it does this by damaging the
cilia tiny hairlike structures whose job
it is to keep the airways clean it then
fills the alveoli tiny air sacs that
enable the exchange of oxygen and carbon
dioxide between the lungs and blood a
toxic gas called carbon monoxide crosses
out membrane into the blood binding to
hemoglobin and displacing the oxygen it
would usually have transported around
the body that's one of the reasons
smoking can lead to oxygen deprivation
and shortness of breath within about 10
seconds the blood stream carries a
stimulant called nicotine to the brain
triggering the release of dopamine and
other neurotransmitters including
endorphins that create the pleasurable
sensations which makes smoking highly
addictive nicotine and other chemicals
from the cigarette simultaneously cause
constriction of blood vessels and
damaged their delicate endothelial
lining restricting blood flow these
vascular effects lead to thickening of
blood vessel walls and enhance blood
platelet stickiness increasing the
likelihood that clots will form and
trigger heart attacks and strokes many
of the chemicals inside cigarettes can
trigger dangerous mutations in the
body's DNA that make cancers form
additionally ingredients like arsenic
and nickel
may disrupt the process of DNA repair
thus compromising the body's ability to
fight many cancers in fact about one of
every three cancer deaths in the United
States is caused by smoking and it's not
just lung cancer smoking can cause
cancer in multiple tissues and organs as
well as damaged eyesight and weakened
bones it makes it harder for women to
get pregnant and in men it can cause a
rectal dysfunction but for those who
quit smoking there's a huge positive
upside with almost immediate and long
lasting physical benefits just 20
minutes after a smokers final cigarette
their heart rate and blood pressure
begin to return to normal after 12 hours
carbon monoxide levels stabilize
increasing the Bloods oxygen carrying
capacity a day after ceasing heart
attack risk begins to decrease as blood
pressure and heart rates normalize after
two days the nerve endings responsible
for smell and taste start to recover
lungs become healthier after about one
month with less coughing and shortness
of breath
the delicate hair like cilia in the
airways and lungs start recovering
within weeks and a restored after nine
months improving resistance to infection
by the one-year anniversary of quitting
heart disease risk plummets to half as
blood vessel function improves five
years in the chance of a clot forming
dramatically declines and the risk of
stroke continues to reduce after 10
years the chances of developing fatal
lung cancer go down by 50% probably
because the body's ability to repair DNA
is once again restored 15 years in the
likelihood of developing coronary heart
disease is essentially the same as that
of a nonsmoker
there's no point pretending this is all
easy to achieve quitting can lead to
anxiety and depression resulting from
nicotine withdrawal but fortunately such
effects are usually temporary and
quitting is getting easier thanks to a
growing arsenal of tools nicotine
replacement therapy through gum skin
patches lozenges and sprays may help
wind smokers off cigarettes
they work by stimulating nicotine
receptors in the brain and thus
preventing withdrawal symptoms without
the addition of other harmful chemicals
counseling and support groups cognitive
behavioral therapy and moderate
intensity exercise also helped smokers
stay cigarette free that's good news
since quitting puts you and your body on
the path back to health if you want to
see more videos on building healthy
habits check out this playlist and if
you want to help support Ted Ed's
nonprofit mission please consider making
a small donation at patreon.com slash
Ted ed
[Music]